حكم غير مسبوق من محكمه ايرانيه قد بسجن
ابنه اختي المرشد الايراني فريده مراد
خاني ثلاث سنوات
عقاب الخال خامنئي لبنه شقيقته جاء بتناقض
واضح مع شعار الفصل بين السلطات وهو
الشاعر الذي لطالم رفعه رجالات النظام في
ايران ولا طالما تم انتهاكه من قبلهم
فمجددا توعد رئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيس
المحتجين بعقاب شديد بما يؤكد استخدام
ذراع القضاء لقمع المتظاهرين فريده هاجمت
اواخر الشهر الماضي وفي بيان المصور خالها
المرشد بسبب قمع اجهزته الامنيه
للاحتجاجات الشعبيه فتم اعتقالها
ومحاكمتها في محكمه خاصه برجال الدين
بتهران بحسب محامها
فريده تدير حمله دعم السجناء في ايران
وامها بدريه حسينيه اخت المرشد علي
الخامنائي من امه وابيه
لا تخان مؤخرا في شريط فيديو نشير بعد
اعتقالها ان الايرانيين انفسهم سيسقطون
النظام وطالبت الدولاب بعدم دعم حكام
ايران الناشطه خاني عاشت في بيئه معارضه
للنظام فوالدها علي مراد خاني قيادي سابق
في النظام الايراني لكن موقفه من النظام
تغير منتصفه ثمانينات بل وبدا بتوجيه
الانتقادات لرجالته حيث سجن لاشهر بمدينه
مشهد ونقل التقارير عالميه ان مراد خان
وعائلته ومن ضمنهم زوجته شقيقه خامنئي
هربوا الى العراق في ذروه الحرب بين
البلدين وعدوا اليها منتصفه التسعينات
فنالا حكما بالسجن لمده 20 عاما قبل ان
يطلق سراحه عام 2005 مراد خانت توفي شهر
الماضي وحتى وفاته استمر بانتقاد استبداد
النظام وارهابه في حق الايرانيين حنان
المصري العربي